let's go next to our caller from the 267
area code who's calling today from 267
David yes
hello hi my name is Greg I'm calling
from Bucks County in Pennsylvania I'm a
big fan of your show thanks Greg a lot
of my a lot of my friends on the Left
honor Bernie supporters as I am and but
I'm getting very concerned about the
idea of a Bloomberg candidacy and I'm
concerned that it will depress it will
depress votes and that we will end up
with Trump again I understand the
arguments that he's kind of he's a
version of Trump but I also lived in New
York for most of my life and I lived
through Bloomberg the Bloomberg
mayorship and I'm interested in what you
had to say to Bernie supporters and
people on the Left who are getting
disappointed about the idea of the
Bloomberg possibility of a Bloomberg
candidacy and the idea that they might
not vote they might sit this out so and
I'd love to hear what they about I think
it's the I I actually I posted to my
Twitter page a few days ago something
like I'm getting emails from some
Democrats saying if Bloomberg's the
nominee they won't vote where are you
guys on this and I got like 6,000
replies from a lot of Democrats saying I
won't vote if it's Bloomberg and I
totally understand that I mean in
Bloomberg you have a guy who represents
a lot of different things you have a guy
who represents a possible sort of
bailout for the of possible bailout for
the establishment that may be seeing Joe
Biden tank and aren't clear about Budaj
and Amy Klobuchar doesn't really have
support if Bloomberg's really polling 15
nationally maybe he's the guy to get
behind but then you have a voter turnout
question which you're bringing up and
the question is if Bloomberg is the
Democratic nominee given that Bloomberg
was a Republican for so long given that
Bloomberg's politics on a lot of social
issues based on videos that have come
out recently seemed to not be
particularly enlightened and progressive
to put it lightly what is it going to do
to turnout and how will he fare against
Donald Trump my answer is I don't know
and the reason I say that is I get
emails about polling that says hey you
know what
face-to-face matchups Bloomberg does
really well against Trump and then I get
other polling that says hey you know
what if Bloomberg's the nominee that
will keep the largest number of
Democratic voters home so I understand
the idea that Bloomberg as the nominee
might depress turnout there are so many
conflicting data points that I just
don't have an answer about that right
now and all I can really say is if you
support the policies of Bernie instead
of Bloomberg just go out and support
Bernie now and then if there's a
different nominee evaluate it and make a
decision as to what's best at that point
yeah absolutely I think it's incredibly
difficult there's not even enough
information yet tonight it's going to be
a whole different spin on this because
of the debates and of course the mention
in media at MSNBC in particular has been
ridiculous this is this is in their anti
in their anti Bernie reads yes so yeah
it's going to be really and one last
question if you had to vote right now
and you had to choose between Trump and
Bloomberg well how would you vote yeah I
I would vote for Bloomberg over Trump
and I know there's a lot of people
saying there's no difference it's just a
richer version of Trump with a lot of
the same ideas the reasons why I would
vote for Bloomberg over Trump are number
one the Supreme Court choices Bloomberg
would make would not be as bad as the
ones Trump would make number two I
remember actually has both sort of
diplomatic and political experience that
Trump lacks which is the source of a lot
of Donald Trump's missteps that would be
number two and then number three
although it would be no great party if
Bloomberg were president Bloomberg would
restore some of the respect from world
leaders that we have lost under Trump
although certainly certainly not all so
for me I wouldn't be cheering about
voting for Bloomberg over Trump but I
definitely vote blue yeah thank you
David I really appreciate your opinion
and I'm a great fan of the show thanks
so much thanks really appreciate hearing
from you thank you so much as many of
you know I am super careful about where
we publish and distribute david pakman
show content it's a really important
decision that we make where do we want
our content to be we don't want to
spread ourselves too thin but we want to
make sure that we're taking advance
good platforms where our content could
do well and over the last couple of
months I've been testing publishing our
content to a platform called library
that's lbr why I've mentioned it once or
twice before and we are absolutely
loving it it's a fantastic platform
where our revenue as publishers does not
depend on some algorithm deciding
whether an ad should run before a video
or not in fact it's actually an ad-free
platform where our revenue is determined
by the number of people that watch our
videos and also by the tips that are
left for us in credits that are in
platform credits it's their own sort of
currency so to speak by viewers like you
and right now for people who sign up on
this platform it's completely free using
the link down in the video description
for every verified signup we get a
little bit of a credit and you also get
a credit of tips that you can then leave
on content that you like such as the
david pakman show content that we are
publishing so use the link down in the
video description
no algorithmic determinations about
whether we get to make money or we don't
get to make money or any of that stuff
all of our video content is being
published there use that link sign up
you'll get a credit we'll get a credit
and it's a beautiful thing and I'll
update you guys in a couple of weeks
about how it's going there's also a
contest that they're running whoever can
refer the most new users gets a huge
reward which would be a big big boost to
us so check it out link down in the
video description sign up let me know
what you think